estos momentos que estamos viendo que
hay millones de personas que están
enfermando y miles que realmente están
sufriendo y muchas de ellas están
realmente muriendo tenemos que utilizar
las vacunaciones de una manera mucho más
efectiva las opciones reales que
nosotros tenemos es ver qué vacunas
tienen un momento para transportación
mucho más efectiva lo que hemos visto en
eeuu con la vacuna de modernas y facer
es que realmente se necesita una
logística muy importante pero también
redes de enfriamiento electricidad y
logística para poder realmente llevar a
cabo esto y también recordar que estas
vacunas en estas dos dosis al momento
que nosotros estamos buscando métodos y
sistemas de salud pública para poder
crear ahora sí que en un país donde
tengamos limitados los recursos es muy
importante reducir las dosis a una y
también la manera de cuidar esas vacunas
que también más es crítico para la
transportación logística y
administración de las mismas
parte de los problemas que nosotros
tenemos en este momento es buscar esos
espacios para que realmente las personas
tengan acceso a parte de esto va a ser
justamente la comunicación porque porque
en este momento tenemos que también
vacunarnos contra el miedo con una dosis
de verdad en estos momentos estamos
viendo de estas cosas que tú busca la
tecnología de las más de 210 vacunas que
están haciendo para aplicarlas a nuestra
comunidad